n'as tu jamais fait l'un de ses rêves
qui ont l'air plus vrai que la réalité
si tu étais incapable de sortir de l'un
de ses rêves comment ferais tu la
différence entre le monde réel et le
monde des rêves citation de morpheus
dans matrix parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
faisons la suite de ma première vidéo
sur les rêves lucides rêve lucide deux
génériques
cette année je vous avais fait une vidéo
sur les rébus idée récemment je vous ai
fait une autre vidéo sur comment se
souvenir des rêves et vous m'avez
reparler d'érable ici donc je vous fais
une suite je regardais également un
petit peu ce qui se faisait dans
d'autres vidéos ça sert à rien que je
leur dise des choses qui sont déjà bien
traités sur youtube et je me suis aperçu
qu'on n'a pas trop parlé des pièges ya
trois pièges principaux qu'on veut
essayer de faire des rêves lucides ou
quand on fait des rêves lui si le
premier piège c'est l'impatience et
d'inconstance
ça peut être très long d'arriver à faire
un rêve lucide moi j'ai mis plus de six
mois en utilisant des méthodes précises
comme celle que je vous avais expliqué
la première fois ou celle que je vais
vous redonnez aujourd'hui et en plus la
première fois qu'on arrive à faire un
rêve lucide soit pas dire qu'on va y
arriver facilement la deuxième fois ça
prend du temps on peut être amené à
lâcher un petit peu ou à être un
constant dans les méthodes
un jour vous y arriverez obligatoirement
imaginer j'ai mis plus de six mois je
vous ai dit c'est long six mois c'est
très très long donc il faut persévérer
le deuxième piège c'est le deus ex
machina le sentiment d'omnipotence dites
vous que quand vous faites un rêve
lucide
vous êtes en train de discuter entre
votre conscience et votre inconscient
donc l'inconscient fabrique le décor les
personnages un petit peu les situations
certaines actions et vous comme vous
êtes conscient vous pouvez peut-être
maîtriser sa et décider de ce que vous
allez faire mais comme dans tout
dialogue
si vous décidez de tous si vous décidez
de changer le décor en permanence de
changer les personnages en permanence si
vous décidez de prendre une conscience
complète du fait que c'est vous qui est
à l'origine de tout ça alors le rêve va
commencer à devenir un petit peu creux
un petit peuple à voir à s'arrêter ce
qui va provoquer le réveil parce que
comme dans n'importe quel dialogue si
l'un des deux n'est coups de tubes à
l'autre se paie et par votre inconscient
il est en train de vous envoyer des
messages de vous donner des informations
sur ce que vous pensez profondément sur
ce qu'ils perturbent lui sur ce qu'il a
envie de vous dire
ne cherchez pas à tout maîtriser du coup
laissé de s'exprimer et de troisième
piège dans lequel on peut tomber suit
logiquement ce deuxième piège ces
lettres satisfaction permanente de ses
désirs au départ qu'on fait des rêves
lucides on veut juste satisfaire ses
envies
savoir voler pour la plupart d'entre
nous à savoir satisfaire des délires je
sais pas moi aller dans l'espace ça va
être une rock star satisfaire sa libido
oui je le sais bon c'est tout à fait
normal mais si vous faites ça en
permanence vous allez perdre votre
motivation est encore une fois vous
n'allez pas laissé le loisir complet à
votre inconscient de vous exprimer ça
reste quand même une bonne manière de
résoudre ces conflits psychologiques de
se connaître un petit peu mieux soi même
c'est aussi une forme de développement
personnel mais quand vous croisez donc
quelqu'un dans le rêve
n'hésitez pas à discuter avec cette
personne n'hésitez par à interagir avec
elle et à savoir ce qu'elle veut vous
dire puisque en fait c'est votre
inconscient qui parle et c'est le
meilleur moyen de parler avec vous même
un des meilleurs conseils pour faire des
rêves lucides reste le travail qu'a fait
paul tollé à ce sujet c'est le premier à
avoir parlé de l'importance de l'esprit
critique dans un rêve lucide
remettez en cause en permanence la
réalité régulièrement demandez vous ce
que vous faisiez il ya cinq minutes il
ya 10 minutes
est-ce que tout est normal est ce que
c'est normal qu'ils soient cette heure
ci est ce que vous avez l'habitude
d'être là quand on rêve on perd
complètement son esprit critique
c'est pour ça qu'on analyse pas toutes
ces choses complètement surprenante est
incroyable puisque c'est notre réalité
on la remet pas en question donc
remettez en question régulièrement la
réalité dans la réalité et vous allez
commencer aussi à le faire par réflexe
dans vos rêves comme pour se souvenir de
vos rêves tenait un journal des rêves ça
c'est important vous pouvez également
vous imprégner avant de vous endormir
vous préparer habituez votre inconscient
à votre habitude du rêve lucide c'est à
dire regardé beaucoup de vidéos sur les
rêves lucides lisez sur les rêves
lucides parler du rêve lucide avec les
autres personnes et comme ça fait partie
de votre quotidien
votre inconscient va ramener ça aussi la
nuit et donc va vous aider et vous
pouvez bien sûr utiliser des stimuli
comme les odeurs ou les sons il ya
certaines applications qui servent aux
rêves lucides y en a une qui s'appelle
smart alarme l envoi des sondes durant
la nuit sur le rêve que tu voudrais
faire pour essayer de te sortir un peu
du sommeil d'entendre ça et de prendre
conscience que tu es en train de rêver
si vous avez d'autres conseils d'une
expérience dans la glu site que vous
voudriez partager n'hésitez pas à nous
le dire dans les commentaires on pourra
s'échanger et se dire ça je serais pas
ce que je sais déjà qu'il ya des
réussites qui vont être un peu what the
fuck n'hésitez pas à l'émeute ou c'est
assez drôle et c'est intéressant en même
temps et quant à moi dans la description
je vous mets deux bouquins que je
recommande je les ai déjà recommandé là
vidéo je vous les recommande de nouveau
aujourd'hui principalement les livres de
stéphane laberge qui a fait d'énormes
travaux là dessus et qui m'ont beaucoup
aidé et n'oubliez pas garder l'esprit
critique sur la réalité en permanence
prenez cette habitude là pour la
retrouver en rêve
j'espère que cette deuxième vidéo sur le
sujet vous aura plu comme d'habitude
vous pouvez laisser un like et vous
abonner à la chaîne et rendez vous
demain à 17h ciao
à tout faire seul
[Musique]